now I remember one of these my sister
had one of these in the 1970s growing up
space invaders was always my favorite
and here it is what great fun it is well
Atari is to release its new first new
games console in 24 years based on the
firm's iconic late seventies design it's
just the latest company to try and cash
in on a wave of nostalgia from vinyl to
Nokia telephones well Elissa a judge is
a host for the entertainment website IGN
hasn't blown me up late listen it will
never go oh gosh I've not played one of
these in years this is a real nostalgia
trip which I guess is kind of a point
come on I've got I've gone into three
lives they're so nice you've left it a
good point for me right
Truong concentrated now you go and vote
then it's a really interesting question
we're seeing it across how many
different industries from vinyl and
coming back in fashion to just fashion
itself I think in gaming it just lends
itself so well to this idea of nostalgia
because games as a kind of wider wider
culture you've got this kind of
community feel nostalgia is built around
this idea of socially saying how you
remember that time and the gaming
community is huge and wide and varied
with all these different forums of just
people feeding that nostalgic trip I saw
in my family is a right old Christmas
tradition you know I mean give me a noun
a couple of glasses of sherry and then
get her on the old space invaders and
we'd all fall about laughing but see is
this aimed at the parents or the kids
then primarily that's a good question
I think primarily it's going to be aimed
at the parents you know the the fact
that we've seen it within as classic
releasing games that are people used to
play back in say the 70s and the 80s the
interesting thing about the new Atari
console is that the hardware there is
hardware now that's more akin to a
modern PC so there's a suggestion that
they might be starting to create at I
might be creating new games and new
gaming experience not just porting over
old ones some how does this compare with
the Xbox or whatever the kids are
playing them these days it's different
it is very different because at the
moment we don't know anything about new
games that could be coming
that would compete with the Xbox and the
PlayStation in terms of modern
high-fidelity graphics that kind of
thing but what it is doing is its
cashing in to the systolic retro gaming
elements which you know PlayStation and
Xbox have tried to do themselves done a
lot of remastered had a crash bandicoot
remaster this year so it's a lot a lot
of gaming companies are seeing the real
business opportunity here yeah Nintendo
they had some success of one of these
recently had a so how do you think this
particular relaunch will go yeah I mean
the nez classic sold 2.3 million units
in just five months so I mean it
properly flew off the shelves I wonder
whether the you know the Atari console
the 2600 was basically it was the
console that started home gaming so it
really holds a special place in gamers
hearts and yeah I can I can see this one
doing really well yeah absolutely
granddad even more there you go nearly
got the mothership all right Alessi
judge you've got to leave it I'm afraid
thank you